[Music]
there's one thing I know about the world
it's not the little things that matter
it's the tiny things do you want yes
cheese is my life my name is Bella and
this is how I met Lucas see those things
I really like you maybe that's a sign
her home supposed to be don't choose
shoes though don't you shoot that one
was his favorite over the years we did
everything together
good we chased squirrel
[Music]
we went to work we even played a game
called doctor doctor doctor gate again
everything all right yeah life with
Lucas was the best but when he wasn't
around I missed him so much that
squirrel again squirrel squirrel
squirrel
[Music]
duck looks like she needs help
okay away the change I was very far from
home but I knew Lucas was waiting for me
and I had to go and find him where needs
when my
even better than a tiny piece of cheese
we all face things that are hard the
only thing that gets us through it are
the special people in our lives and I
was never going to stop searching until
I found mine
[Music]
that dog saved his life
[Music]
you
[Music]
you